sie haben sich haben sich zur Aufgabe
gemacht Gabe gemacht gegen Mobbing
vorzugehen gegen Gewalt in unserer
Gesellschaft so wirklich friedfertig ist
das was die klimakaoten in den letzten
Tagen und Wochen getan haben dann aber
doch nicht oder also wenn man sich das
jetzt mal so anguckt dann frage ich mich
wirklich manchmal was ist es in unserer
Gesellschaft geschehen und wann sind der
ein oder andere falsch abgebogen ich
kämpfe seit Jahren vor allem für den
Kinderschutz in unserem Land werden
tagtäglich Kinder missbraucht und das
mache ich als Aktivist im Kinderschutz
ich habe mich noch nirgendwo festgeklebt
habe noch keine innere Sicherheit
bedroht oder irgendwelche Menschen daran
gehindert zur Arbeit zu kommen oder zum
Beispiel die Feuerwehr der gehindert
Menschen wird Leben zu retten und genau
das machen Sie hier viele von denen
haben noch niemals gearbeitet viele von
den kommen aus reichen Elternhäusern
keine Ahnung was da auch immer schief
gelaufen ist das rechtfertigt nichts
aber wenn die Politik und auch viele
verantwortliche Politik auf dem linken
und dem grünen Auge blind sind dann wird
soweit auch akzeptiert die Frage ist
doch welche Strafen bekommen sie hat 200
300 Euro dann machen Sie immer weiter
aber vielleicht müssten sie einfach mal
in Knast für ein paar Tage unter einfach
mal vielleicht gerade Latin Latein
putzen können sie ja sich vielleicht
auch festkleben aber da wollen sie
wahrscheinlich schnell wieder raus und
wie bei ihr sehen haben bei Porsche
haben sich dann beschwert das Licht aus
war das ist kalt wurde dass man nicht
auf Toilette war ich meine was wollt ihr
ja ach ihr wollt trotzdem ihr eine
exklusive Behandlung aber den Menschen
der Leben zur Hölle machen und der tun
ja nicht nur die haben der tut ja auch
zum Teil die 20% nicht mal 20% ihr
wählte grüne Parteien in unserem Land
die HD Vorläufer dafür sind und jetzt
sehen wir das und anscheinend ist das
normal aber es fördert die Wut den Hass
und auf der anderen Seite gibt es ja
nicht immer wieder auch Menschen die
extrem sind und ich habe einfach Angst
dass die irgendwann aufeinanderprallen
und dann haben wir ganz unschöne Zähne
sie haben gerade gesagt das fördert die
Wut die Wut ist aber auch schon da denn
es gibt Menschen die haben eben keine
Geduld mehr mit diesem Menschen die sich
auf der Straße festkleben die den
Berufsverkehr behindern es gab eine
Szene in Berlin vor wenigen Tagen da
sind die Menschen dann auch einfach
ausgeflippt ich weiß nicht ob wir sie
vorliegen haben vielleicht können wir
noch mal reingucken nein haben wir nicht
aber da ist wirklich ist jemand aus dem
Auto ausgestiegen und hat einfach
versucht einen ein von diesen
klimaaktivisten Weg zu schleppen wie
gefährlich ist sowas wie sie können Sie
beschäftigen sie sich nun auch mit dem
Thema Gewaltprävention es ist natürlich
ein gewaltiger Kessel der da brodelt ja
da sitzen die die ihre Ideologien
durchsetzen wollen und die glauben sie
machen das Richtige wenn ja politisch
auch immer wieder abgefangen und
gestützt und die Menschen die einfach
die Schnauze voll haben die diese ganzen
Probleme sowieso schon spielen
vielleicht auch soziale Probleme haben
nicht mehr wissen ihre Miete bezahlen
wollen und natürlich dann diese Menschen
sehen und sowas kann sich ganz schnell
entladen und die lassen sich ja nicht
friedlich wegzehren die Zahlen ja zurück
also mein dass man schon sagen muss geht
schon soweit nein man muss die Polizei
rufen und jetzt kleben die sich ja fest
auch die Polizei kann nicht einfach
wegnehmen ich persönlich sage wir werden
noch sehr viel andere unschöne Szenen
sehen und ich hoffe dass die Politik
hier ein Zeichen setzt damit die wissen
dass das keine nachah
Reihenfolge sein darf weil es wird ja
immer schlimmer man merkt ja die kleben
sich überall fest für beschmieren
Gemälde die unbezahlbar sind und sie
sind alle Dinge wo ich sage es reicht es
reicht sie haben gerade gesagt die
Menschen haben andere Probleme
Existenzängste unter anderem
Bundespräsident Frank-Walter Steinmeier
hat heute eine Rede an die Nation
gehalten und uns auf eine schwierige
Zukunft eingestimmt hören wir da einmal
gemeinsam rein es kommen härtere Jahre
raue Jahre auf uns wenn wir im Gegenwind
stehen anstatt uns weiter
auseinandertreiben zu lassen
müssen wir alles stärken mit diesem
Winter ist es nicht getan so sehr uns
die Sorgen vor Inflation Energiepreisen
und den Krieg gerade umtreiben
es wird auch nach diesem Winter auch
nach dieser wirtschaftlichen Talsohle
kein einfaches zurück zum davor geben
können und es beginnt für Deutschland
eine Epoche im Gegenden
kein Zurück mehr zum davor titelt seine
Rede alles Stärken was uns verbindet der
Versuch uns einzuschwören aber während
Deutschlands Staatsoberhaupt im Schloss
Bellevue sprach hörte kein einziger
Vertreter der Bundesregierung zu sieht
so Zusammenhalt aus Herr
Steinmeier einen grünen Waschlappen im
Grünen Waschlappen mit dem kann er sich
dann auch gerne waschen denn wenn man
solche Vorschläge macht und solche Dinge
hört ich frage mich Herr Steinmeier wann
fangen sie denn mal an Opfer und dem
Währung zu bringen und in einer dermaßen
Krise erheben die sich und sagen wir
bauen für 777 Monate wird er nicht
reichen ein Kanzleramt weiter damit Herr
unser Prinz of Wales noch mal ein
schönes 250 Quadratmeter hat wurde aber
das ist also eure Art wie ihr die
Menschen darauf einschürt dass sie
Entbehrung bringen sollen wir sind aber
ich überlasse ihn den hier machen sie
Eis drin legt euch den als Regierung
schön auf den Kopf vielleicht hilft ja
eure grauen Zellen bisschen anstrengen
wenn ihr etwas von uns fordert dann
fangt bei euch selber an wir helfen
gerne wir helfen gerne aber was wenn wir
nicht mehr helfen können wenn die
Menschen nicht mehr können wenn kein
Geld mehr das wenn die wildschaft im
Arsch ist wen sollen wir dann noch
helfen ach ich vergaß sie bringt ja
keine Opfer sie erhöhen sich in einer
niederwiesenen Krise die Diäten sie
machen ihre Gehälter höher und im
Europaparlament werden Parlament wird
sogar um die Inflationsrate die Gehälter
angepasst so sieht also eure Moral aus
was für eine Heuchlerei was für eine
verschissene Doppelmoral sorry muss ich
sagen sie haben das kannst denkt trotz
Bau das gerade angesprochen wir gucken
uns das noch mal ein damit wirklich auch
an damit auch wirklich jeder weiß um was
es sich da handelt ja also aus gut
25.000 Quadratmeter beruffläche soll mit
Hilfe eines Erweiterungsbaus rund 50.000
Quadratmeter werden plus Kita für die
Mitarbeiter und Heli Landeplatz auf 23
Meter hohen Stelzen auch eine zweite
kanzlerwohnung ist vorgesellt sehen
Fertigstellung
Fertigstellung ich bin das auch ganz in
Rage 2028 Kosten
777 Millionen Euro damit wäre das
Kanzleramt größer als das Weiße Haus die
Downing Street und der elise-palast in
Paris ist es nicht schön dass wir in so
einer Krise wird haben und was sagt
unser ich vergesse alles Kanzler ja das
war ja schon vorher geplant wissen Sie
Herr Kanzler in der Krise beweist sich
der Charakter sie haben doch die
Möglichkeit zu sagen nein wir fangen bei
uns an zu sparen deswegen wird auf Eis
gelegt nein sie schieben es auf die
andere Regierung sagen wir müssen es
weitermachen brauchen sie so eine
potenzverlängerung brauchen Sie ein 250
Quadratmeter Ballast wirklich ist es
soweit ganz ehrlich für mich ist das
einfach nur noch unerträglich dir zu
hören deswegen muss sofort hier stoppt
werden viele Gelder müssen auch gestoppt
werden und wenn ich dann höre was wir
überall helfen sollen und machen und tun
wir in unserem Land brauchen auch hilfe
wo macht er denn Hilfe jetzt zum
arzthall da passiert da auch nicht da
liegt alles da und wie gesagt mit euren
Brot kommen dir den Menschen zu schmeißt
hier in euren Ticket da 300 € da das
funktioniert nicht und glaubt mir die
Menschen haben die Schnauze voll ich
spreche für Millionen von Menschen da
draußen und ich sag's Ihnen auch ins
Gesicht Herr Steinmeier und Herrn Scholz
ich weiß Sie haben sich am nächsten Tag
wieder vergessen ist nicht so schlimm
ich werde weiter den Mund aufmachen weil
die Menschen einfach nicht mehr können
und ihr habt die Pflicht zuallererst für
die Menschen in unser Land einzustehen
hier dafür zu sorgen dass die Menschen
nicht frieren und eure Waschlappen die
könnt ihr euch sonst wohin stecken
[Musik]